today i'm very excited because we're
checking out a tlc
classic i've heard about this i've never
actually seen the story but it's a guy
that likes to
engage with the cars let's just put it
that way until the video has gotten
started a little bit
spoopy spoopy
this is the first time we have a guy
actually on i just realized all the
women likes to eat stuff
but guys like to no no my name is
27 years old oh my god who does he look
like oh god
oh this is going to paint me oh no
and i'm in a serious relationship with
my car oh
he's the bottom guy all right
no no
i didn't expect them to just jump into
it i can't look at this
children look away don't do any so
that's the mouth of the car i assume or
maybe it isn't i mean who knows
i don't know what kind of fantasy he
engaged with okay it's either other oh
there's a steering wheel good morning
baby
my handsome man hand oh it's a man all
right i respect i respect that even more
nathaniel is in a committed relationship
with a car
committed how what is that
what does committed mean in this context
i need to know
oh my gosh dude he's named chase
he met chase that's a good name i'll
[ __ ] with chase i'm not gonna sit and
lie to you or he's a sexy beast
um he can see himself in the reflection
that
makes it kind of weird doesn't it not
that that's like the weirdest thing out
of this
okay i'm it was love at first sight his
body and then his interior and
everything just together just seemed to
fit and i just felt an instant
connection
this has to be a psychological condition
but i never heard about it
being in love with inanimate objects
it's just that i guess
i can understand that but the car in
itself is just
nathaniel's obsession first developed as
a teenager when he would build model
cars
but he didn't find true love until he
met chase
i find this part of him the most sexy
just because the subtle lines and curves
ooh he's a curb guy and i got no
quarrels with his
logic so far at least chase curved guy i
mean
[ __ ] kiss here and just kind of
caress him down the side
oh my initial reaction i was kind of
shocked
that shot is just terrible him laying
underneath
it was kind of weird because it was just
hard to understand
okay here it is okay nice objectophilia
is when a person develops a strong
emotional sexual relationship with an
inanimate object objectophilia
okay some cases include attraction to a
rollercoaster
an elevator or the eiffel tower i mean
come
i the eiffel tower i understand that
sounds like some awful hentai
someone saw that was like
[Music]
honestly i don't know why i feel the way
i do it
but i just absolutely love chase
we always have such a good time together
he likes a lot of the same music i do
we have a favorite song that's great
they share common interests this is
phenomenal
it's a cool car can't fight this feeling
mario speedwagon
i do getting guess how you buy something
for your fiance or your wife
and then usually for his birthday i try
to do something special for him too
the favorite date would be going to the
lookout area
oh lean against him a little bit
i love you nathaniel's relationship with
chase
goes beyond dates and presents i don't
know if i i want i'm not ready to go
beyond me right
oh okay here we go
there we go sometimes we get sexual no
does that feel good you did not have to
film that
tlc you snoopy lousy
they're like okay so like explain us
what you do with this car
do you ever anything you know beyond
dates and kissing
yeah sometimes we get the sometimes we
get funky i get funky with the car
we're gonna film that can you do that
right now actually let's wait for it to
get dark we wanted to
set the moon right it'll be like we're
not there we'll be outside the
windshield
we'll get a zoom cr swim crop lights
don't worry about it you just do
do what do your thing pretend that we're
not there
oh handsomely handsome man
you my my man what are you doing around
these parts of town mr
chase wow a cadillac like yo i don't
know what
car it is what we do the most often is i
like to lean over his fender
and across his hood and uh he likes that
crack
things like that and uh and kind of
press up against him and just
and rub against him like that one of his
more
bold positions is for me to be
underneath him no
[Music]
i can't his celebrity question is
lightning mcqueen i just saw that
if he's comfortable doing this on camera
imagine what he does with no camera
where would i [ __ ] a car oh
oh
no no no i am worried
my friend because it's oh get out of the
brain get out of brain
delete from brain why did i think that
stop it and
you may have people that don't
understand and make fun of you
now that's a shot they were like this is
it
this is golden we got this nathaniel's
so attached to chase
he rarely lets anyone else drive him and
never lets chase out of his sight for
more than 24 hours
there have been times it brought tears
to my eyes because i wasn't with him
it worked his picture's on my desktop so
i see his face all the time
it really bothers me when he gets dinged
or scratched
if someone were ever having chase my
heart would just stop
i'm just have to he's crying just
thinking about it
i am concerned for nathaniel emotion was
i think life would be easier if he did
change
love you nathaniel's roommate kim
is one of the few people who know the
full extent of his love life
i guess the reason i don't tell a lot of
people is because i don't know the
response i'm gonna get
he's worried about the disgust so i'm
gonna go on national television i'm sure
no one's gonna have a problem with how
his relationship
could affect his career as a customer
service technician
he's a customer service technician hey i
got your car all fixed up don't worry
about it hey
why is there all this uh stuff no no
i don't want to joke about it it may
affect my job
but i love him today i'm worried it's
gonna affect my job so i'm going on
television why
why do they do this i hope tlc pays them
well
right right it's inevitable that it's
gonna break at some point right
i mean i guess he knows how to fix it
this sounds like a weird anime
help i'm in love with my car season one
was really good but it really gets
ridiculous at season two
i'm curious if there's more of these
objectophilia oh roller coaster showed
up
married to the eiffel tower i think i've
heard about this oh that's 45 minutes i
don't know
okay here's an amusement ryan
i love this part that's coming up it's
not unlike
one of box coral preludes and i think
because they're german they adapted this
right here
he's orchestrating it
[Applause]
[Music]
she's just playing along like oh yeah
this is sick bro okay but tell us why
you love it i need to know
wow he is really tall yes he is
he is tall indeed
i mean i get it
after five months it's good it's good to
see
you
[Laughter]
it's strangely kind of sweet and i don't
know
so proud so strong
not only love him all right those are
not adjectives i would use but i mean
hell
that's what you see art is subjective
right i mean we're not talking about
fetish here
i love him as a mate oh
his counterweights at the top i love him
for the narrowness of his jibs
ooh i love him for the elegant lines of
his gondola which is
now covered up for the winter i like
your ribbing
up underneath his name display there too
now there's more parallel lines that are
coming down the parallel lines of course
of course yeah i love that too
[Music]
i'm thinking oh geez you know what i'm
thinking about
no no i really don't
i have no idea what the [ __ ] this is
very personal
when i make love to him hold up
hold up how what why when how
how how how do you
just as i'm starting to go over the edge
i just tell them i want your fluids i
want your fluids i want your fluids
[Music]
you just made it really really weird i
want your fluids
okay
i'm not judging oh she's
been down and dirty oh she's
putting it on our face
[Applause]
this is can we hear that again this is
not fetish
i did not expect to find a fence like
this here at all
he's perfect i mean this is the shape
that i like so much these angles
fabulous what why why are you talking
about the fence now
what is happening what is happening
you're cutting to a fence she loves the
fence
what you can't just jump to a fence what
is going on
back to her oh oh
god you smell so good
uh-huh okay sure
what about the fence what happened with
the i don't all right we i've seen
enough of people making out with objects
oh she sits on it no that's it that's
enough internet for today
i i'm definitely physically attracted to
this fence
um and i would like to get to know this
fence better you just met
you just met even for human standards
that's foul
you can't just sit on someone's face the
first thing you do when you meet them
imagine whoever built that fence see
this video and be like
wait what that this is not why i built
the fence
i it's weird because like if it wasn't
sexual i would kind of think it's kind
of sweet and cute
in a weird way but the whole making out
and no one want to feel that's as
[ __ ] i don't know man i'm intrigued
by this i need to know
uh how this occurs it's a uh-huh okay
but how to
there's really not much information at
all here we go what causes it
some experts believe that it caused by
childhood trauma such as uh
other others subject that objects or
situation can become sexually arousing
if they are frequently and repeatedly
associated with a
pleasurable sexual activity i think we
can all agree that's enough internet for
today
very entertaining i will say subscribe
if you enjoyed this video i make more
videos and
see you tomorrow profess